If you're a girl, you're not afraid of clouds.The other day I was consulted about giant spiders,
and they weren't particularly scary.They just had
long legs, and you could easily break their heads with your fists.Well
, I'm
used to
snakes.Insects.  It seems like you're okay too. If you're
afraid of insects and can't
go to mountains or abandoned houses where monsters live, then you're already hated because of the hardships.
Even if you're not hated.  If you've been in a relationship for a long time, there will be
ups and downs, so it's
nothing to be afraid of.If that's the case, you won't be afraid of being
abandoned due to hardships.It's as if you've already been abandoned.That's not the
case.  It doesn't matter.
It's not even close to being sent by a stalker. It's because
your parents like you that you're staying at my house and you're so inconvenient. Your
parents are here, too.  What's so good about someone like this, Tachibana-san?
You
can often say that much to your lover's cousin, so I
know that if I tell you what I'm afraid of, it won't turn out badly. Well
then, Mr. Tachibana.  What are you scared of?
You are the most scary,
Kotoko-san.